[Music]
hey i'm willow smith and this is my
glamour
unfiltered
[Music]
i think that it's only important for me
to challenge conventional wisdom
if that conventional wisdom
um in some way
says that it's not okay for someone to
be the fullest version of who they are
or it's not okay for them to
express what's inside of them if that's
not
outwardly hurting anybody else
[Music]
something that i do to just kind of
practice
being the most authentic version of
myself
um is every day there's gonna be an
opportunity
where you can say what's really on your
mind
or you can just try to not rock the boat
and i think that recognizing those
moments
and being aware in those moments and
making the decision to advocate for
yourself advocate
for your expression advocate for your
rights even
somebody else's rights like you know
like even if they're not even if it
doesn't
specifically pertain to you um to just
be aware
in those moments and to show up and
speak up in those moments
living on earth and observing nature
has taught me so much about what
the divine feminine truly is and
the amount of nurturing and
caring and honestly tough love
and and power that
mother earth represents mother earth is
the ultimate mother
so yeah i i get all of my femininity
advice from her
[Music]
i think that people are starting to
realize that
you can't tell a human who they are the
human has to tell you who they are um
so personally i think that
you know back in the day when we were
living
in tribes and connected to the earth
um we understood that more deeply
and since we've you know moved away from
that kind of life
and started living in cities and using
phones and saying
this area is mine and you can't come
here
we just lost that like we just kind of
we just kind of lost that
so we just have to bring it back and we
have to be aware
in the ways that we bring that
compassion
and that understanding and that
and that community back in a world where
it's not conducive to that kind of
connection or that kind of understanding
[Music]
you can't you can't change how other
people think or feel about you
um because their reality is their
reality
and the only thing you can do is is
try to do something good with what
you've been given
and if you don't try to do something
good with what you've been given then
what's the purpose of of you having this
what's the purpose of
even i mean yeah like what's the purpose
of you
even being here so that's what i tell
myself
it's not worth it if you don't try to
help people
like none of it none of it is worth it
if you're not in service
um and so
just trying to do that in all the
different ways that you possibly can
i've had a lot of time to
sit and just think about a lot of my
childhood a lot of my
childhood traumas that that still seep
in
to my life today and spending so much
time at home and having
and just having so much time on my hands
to
to explore those things not even
like honestly against my will at times
because when you're just sitting at home
things come up and your mind starts your
mind just starts going and sometimes
you're not even choosing to to
address these things but they're coming
up so you better address it or it's
never going to get fixed
from being in the limelight
from such a young age there's a huge
there's a huge trigger of feeling like
i'm
only valued when i'm entertaining or
when i'm performing and i'm not
valued as just
me without without
putting on a show and trying to do the
things you know
um and that's it that that hurts because
everyone wants to be loved not for what
they do but for who they are
um and so when i start to feel like
when i start to feel like i'm only being
valued because of my
performance or because of my whatever
anything that doesn't have to do with
who i truly am
i get very triggered and very very
anxious and very
sad and scared very quickly i'm grateful
for everything in my life even the
things that don't go the way i want them
to
and you know i just try to drill that in
and drill that in and drill that in and
not allow my mind to go to anywhere else
but that place
[Music]
people of color
not even just in the rock world
are underrepresented in general
um specifically women of color
um if we're gonna narrow down even more
um and so it's not even just about rock
even though that's a very heavily
white male dominated space um
[Music]
i think that i just want to express
my desire and my anger at the fact
that just people of color and women of
color
haven't been given the freedom to just
be who we want to be
without being challenged for it and
questioned because of it
and all of these different things and
honestly even being
even being attacked and vi and violently
violently attacked because of it
[Music]
it's about time like like we're sick and
tired
like like we are done
being pushed to the side attacked
violated and no one caring
like we're just we're just done and it's
honestly that simple
at a certain point
i want my music to
serve a double purpose of
yeah like you can listen to this and
have fun and turn your mind off
and and you know live in the moment but
also
you're not gonna be ingesting like
poison into your mind
um and it's actually gonna be planting a
seed
that is going to help you later in life
and not give you these weird murky
dark feelings and thoughts later in life
that you really didn't know where it
came from it's because you were
listening to this
negative hateful music
um or not even just music but like what
we watch what we read who we follow
on social media like all of those things
you are what you eat you are what you
ingest you are
what you expose yourself to um
and i just want to be
one of the things that you can expose
yourself to that hopefully will make you
feel more love for yourself and the
people around you
it's starting to erode
the efficiency and honesty and ease with
which we can communicate with people in
our
in our close-knit community yeah um
and that's a problem because those are
the people that we need to communicate
with and those are the people that we
need to
it's our community like it's real life
those are the people that we need to be
helping and communicating with and
creating with in order to make our
community a better place and
and so on and so on and so on
not very well um but the but the failure
how i think about failure is
like not being as compassionate as i
know i should have been in that
situation
not being as honest as i know i should
have been in that situation
not bringing my all to
to an artistic endeavor that i knew
needed my all
i feel most empowered when i have the
courage to advocate for myself in a
radical way
and i feel most empowered when
i feel like i've done something really
really well
to take all of the different experiences
all of the different heartbreaks and
pains and
horrendous mistakes and put it all
together
and create a goddess warrior of a woman
of yourself
the only thing that truly matters in
life
is
having meaningful connections with your
fellow brothers and sisters
the universe is infinite
and we know this scientifically
um yeah there is no way that there's
not infinite amounts of species out
there
doing their thing kicking it around and
wondering the same question
huh wonder if there's some other people
out there
you know so hopefully one day if there
are any extraterrestrials
looking at this right now beam me up
because i'm down to meet your leader i'm
down to know what the vibe is
um and that's where i'm at